my name is Dave Ackley I thought I would
introduce Dave by sort of introducing
myself for a couple of minutes because
it's what's most important to me uh how
many how many folks were here both
Tuesday and Wednesday ah ok you're the
people I want to talk to now yesterday
you heard Walter Fontana speak here and
he knew Dave for ages since he was a
platypus and on Tuesday you heard from
gym rat who has known everybody forever
as far as I can tell ah but I've only
known Dave since after he came to SF I
so i'm actually a crack our newbie we've
had some meetings we've talked but I
have this weird feeling that I know him
much better than I should given the data
and I think I know why that is now it's
those damn mirror neurons uh-uh you see
ya he's in my brain and the part of my
brain that represents him is the same
part of the brain that represents myself
so what I see him thinking I think
and the hell of it is half the time he
thinks my thoughts better than I do yeah
and and and that that's something now of
course some of the time he thinks my
thoughts in such a profoundly wrong way
that I have to slap him in my mind so
here I am we have these what I do is
computers I'm a computer guy I'm at UNM
down in Albuquerque and what I would
like to do is look at how I think Dave
is looking at intelligence and how he's
looking at living things from the other
side not from the side of how natural
systems do it but how systems like
computers do it or fail to do it really
um so that's that's part of the struggle
that I have in my mind between the day
of crack power in my brain and the Dave
Ackley also in my brain is that I like
those machines that they was talking
smack about for the last two days you
know these profoundly stupid things that
and it's true they are profoundly stupid
you have to be extremely literal when
you talk to these machines for example
when I'm wearing my computer science had
you know did you notice that Dave would
give us these little warnings when it
was time to put on his thing thinking
cap but he never told us when we could
take it off uh-uh so if i'm wearing my
computer science hat I've got three
thinking caps on now and if he asked me
to put on another one I'm gonna have to
be Darwin or Einstein or I'm gonna have
to settle for texting but then
biological systems real living systems
they aren't like that they take care of
themselves they just sorta yeah I don't
need that anymore machines don't do that
computers as we have them today don't do
that so I do computers not only do i do
computers i do artificial life with
computers so what I'm trying to do is
take these profoundly stupid machines
and somehow make them act more lifelike
whatever that might mean in some context
and defining life is pretty much just as
hard as defining intelligence it might
even be related they might not be
separate concepts and computers today
are incredibly stupid I mean you know we
have a desktop we make a folder you know
that's not a folder I mean that's a
picture of something I can't cut my
finger on that folder I can't whip it
across the room I can't burn it for heat
it's not a folder the the world inside
the computer that we have today is a
complete Hollywood false set it's just
the front it's just a coat of paint it's
reality a hundred miles wide and one
pixel deep and I think that's what bugs
Dave about it so much that natural life
evolved life is very deep and the
machines that we're making today so far
are pitiful shallow almost insulting you
call that a folder
but hey I mean you know this is my job I
make these things I do what I can do
natural life had quite a head start
three billion years on the whole planet
70 years since Colossus at Bletchley
Park so we're doing pretty well for
these machines and the history and
machines is really just beginning in the
history of the interactions between man
between natural living systems and their
technologies it's not just beginning
either it's been going on for a long
time but now these technologies are kind
of turning into a new era a new kind of
machine a new kind of interaction
between people and machines and I think
as much as anybody I know I think Dave
Krakouer probably knows where we're
going and I'm hoping that's what he's
going to tell us tonight so let's get
ladies and gentleman David cracker
is a hard act to follow all right well I
don't know we were going I'll fess up
for that right now so let me summarize
so the first night I try to expand the
definition I didn't give you one your
conception of intelligence giving you a
sense that it was ubiquitous in nature
and what its critical ingredients are
yesterday I talked at length about the
cell and its incredible powers and I
think in some sense that's what Dave was
referring to what I would call you know
ubiquity that way right vertical
ubiquity that there's intelligence all
the way down in us and that doesn't seem
to be the case yet in machines and we'll
see that's probably where they have to
go again apologies you're probably
wearing about six of these by now but
for the biological organisms in the
audience they understand that you have
to sort of take it off after a few
slides the point that I was making at
the end of yesterday's lecture is that
one of our extraordinary characteristics
is to externalise representations
abstract features of the natural world
and represent them in a shared workspace
which allows us to build up ideas and
intelligence culturally something that
other animals don't do as well but it
would be too strong to claim that they
don't do it at all and I gave that
example of niche construction yesterday
but at a certain point in our history
something interesting happened and we
created representations of abstractions
that were also inferential okay so we no
longer just drew the solar system we
drew them into a machine that could
simulate it so we've created tools with
an additional capability that goes
beyond a a planar static representation
and very recently as they've correctly
pointed out we've created machines that
aren't just representational and aren't
just inferential
but they're also strategic and this
means that we've created something that
at least by my definition possesses most
if not all of the hallmarks of
intelligence and our we have I think a
basic intuition that this is true and in
some sense it leads to a polarized
response to the computer there are those
who view the computer as the utopian
solution to all of the problems that we
face as a society and those who take a
slightly dystopian perspective who
believe that in the end the machines
will be our undoing so I'm just going to
show you one clip of a movie and I have
my computer read you a poem that reflect
those two perspectives and hopefully the
sound will be loud enough so that you
can hear this click the first clip comes
from the science fiction movie at the
matrix the human body generates more
bioelectricity than a 120 volt battery
5,000 BTU combined with a form of fusion
the machines had found all the energy
they would ever need
you can hear me oh good exit yes so to
turn us into this we have a summer
school every year at the Santa Fe
Institute and we get to pose questions
to the students and my question was is
the future of humanity to be a battery
for a computer and I meant it somewhat
facetiously and a young computer
scientist from Edinburgh said of course
we're batteries who builds the nuclear
facilities that provide the power for
the computers who digs the mines who
builds the dams of course where
batteries for the computers already and
always have been this seems to have a
lot of echo on it I'd like to think and
the sooner the better of a cybernetic
meadow where mammals and computers live
together in mutually programming harmony
like pure water touching clear sky I
like to think right now please of a
cybernetic forest filled with pines and
electronics where deer stroll peacefully
passed computers as if they were flowers
with spinning blossoms I like to think
it has to be of a cybernetic ecology
where we are free of our Labor's and
joint back to nature return to our
mammal brothers and sisters and all
watched over by machines of loving grace
right so those two couldn't be more
contrasting positions on our future this
of course was written by Richard
Brautigan as a novelist and poet and he
in some sense represents the tradition
that goes back to marks that technology
will be our liberation it'll give us the
time we need to be created and free and
I don't really know which of these two
positions I should adopt yet so
yesterday I showed you some plots where
we looked at body mass against brain
signs and that was called the in
capitalization quotient okay now i'm
showing you a plot of the growth in the
cranial volume of this hominid lineage
through time so for those at the back
this is millions of years starting at
minus 7 million up to the present
and what we're measuring here is the
volume of the cranium and this trend in
event is called an exponential trend it
increases it's more than linear which
means that as we move into the present
there's a very very rapid accumulation
of volume okay and as I pointed out
yesterday cranial volume is correlated
of course with brain size which is
correlated with neural the number of
neurons in your brain which is
considered at least for some part of the
brain to be a correlate of what we might
call intelligence but we understand
hopefully since yesterday that there are
limits now people working on machines
have been looking at very similar trends
now the only difference here is we're
looking at the logarithm of the axis and
so it looks linear okay but it's still
exponential suiting okay and so you
probably can't read this at the bat but
this comes from reycarts vials work and
many of you might have heard of him he's
been arguing for this idea called the
singularity and we'll get to it and so
what we have here is this is
calculations per second per thousand
dollars and so in 1950 you had one
calculation per second per thousand
dollars and this only takes us up to two
the year 2000 we have I don't know like
something like 10 to the eighth
calculations per second per thousand
dollars a huge increase in the number of
calculations are performed by a chip and
the what's behind this is something
known as Moore's law that the number of
transistors per chip doubles every two
years so huge increase in computing
power in a very short period of time
this is the same idea but for memory for
that is the hard drive your hard drive
store storage capability again looking
back to nineteen fifty we have about one
bitch right per dollar and we come took
the present now and it's on the order of
10 billion per dollar so in no time
there's been a huge increase both in the
processing power right and in the
storage capacity and kurt's file has
suggested that if we project that trend
forward but sometime between 2040 and
2050 we'll cross a temporal threshold
that he calls the singularity we're in
memory and processing power
computers will outpace us now there's a
lot of argument about how he calculates
that I don't really care and I'm and
whether you believe in the singularity
or not doesn't really matter the point
is they are very quickly becoming
extremely powerful that's all we need to
worry about and what are the
implications of the power well here's a
brain it could be a cell that I use a
brain for the following reason and as I
said it has these interesting
characteristics and you know it can do
things like write books we can represent
narrative externally are we can build
devices that have the capability of
inference and more recently we've
externalized concepts of strategy very
simple forms of strategy but what these
scaling laws give us is they give us one
tool that does all of them you know the
wrong one ring to rule them all this is
it this is this is this is the one tool
that can do everything that the brain
can do right this is the property of
universality associated with chirring
chirring basically was interesting the
idea that you could have one machine
that could run multiple different
functions on it as long as those
functions could be described through a
system of rules okay and so you have
ebooks right you have calculators and
calculating devices and so forth because
all of those can be represented by the
one machine that's the characteristic of
universality and that's a characteristic
that's assumed to be possessed by the
brain and so if the brain can simulate a
computer and the computer can simulate
the brain that gives rise to a notion of
equivalence but somehow we finally come
up with a thing that is a deep sense
equivalent to what we mean by a brain or
by an intelligent organ and the
implications of that things like this
night report reveals sixty-five percent
of the US consumers are spending more
time with their computers than with
significant others now we all know
that's true and we all know it's an
understatement and apologies to my wife
but she does the same thing in reverse
and the reason why that's so unfair is
because they haven't understood the
concept of universality because the
point about the computer is in the old
days if you went back to the 1940s what
would you do well you read where you'd
read a book you might talk to your
friends you might read the newspaper you
might watch a film you might listen to
music you might do some writing you
might do some research the point is now
you will do it on the same machine right
and so that would take up more than
sixty five percent of your time to it's
just the case that now you can blame one
object rather than having to blame six
or seven now an interesting approach to
our the brain in relation to computers
is associated with this chair this is
john von neumann a very important figure
here for us and what he did is he said
the following he said we built computers
evolution built brains that means we
should understand how computers work and
if there is some form of equivalence
between computers and brains then maybe
the mathematics that we use to
understand computers will generalize to
understanding brains so that was his
approach and he wrote a very famous book
he wrote it in 1956 he was very ill is
published in 1958 posthumously and the
book was called the computer and the
brain it's a very interesting book is
only 96 pages long so it won't take you
long to read now and he describes it as
an approach towards understanding the
nervous system from the mathematicians
viewpoint so even though I might have
been disparaging about machines I think
one of the things that building
Universal representational tools gives
us is a whole new way of thinking about
the brain that biologists on their own
would never have thought of however
there has been a very interesting
bifurcation so epistemological their
meaning a bifurcation in our knowledge
in our understanding that is on the one
you have people who are really only
interested in the pragmatic and you have
others like von Neumann interested in
the scientific meaning people interested
in just building better and better tools
and I have an example on the stage it's
very funny last night apparently and not
sure it's going to work if Simon's it
does that do I just press it on what
does it do this is a this is a vacuum
cleaner and it's supposed to do
something when you turn it on it's
supposed to move Simon yeah well
normally this thing if it was
intelligent would move and it would
clean the stage but instead last night
in the middle of the night mysteriously
it turned itself on and destroyed the
chess set and so apparently they had to
come in and reconstitute it and they are
worried that I'd set it up in some
special way so obviously it is
intelligent it's just denying it at the
moment okay so oh alright I was worried
that it would in fact go off the edge
but look you see it Lex ever this is
this was donated to me by my colleague
Simon to do because he's too lazy to
clean his own floor but anyway you get
it that's what's meant by our machine
intelligence in the 21st century um so
this would be an instance of the
pragmatic outsourcing of a form of
representation this thing has to let me
look at it pause before it went over the
edge that's an ability to sense its
environment and respond adaptively with
respect to its own functional goals
right and and that that's quite
different from understanding how the
brain works the kind of thing that von
Neumann was doing and this is a real
problem at the moment because we have
two communities who have very very
different goals with respect to machine
intelligence and the question is will
this ever happen and I think some of us
believe it has to because if you want to
go beyond that right and beyond a chess
machine which I'll talk about to build a
robot that's generally useful they can
play chess with you and wash your dishes
at that point this might start to happen
so let's go back to chess
so for many many years chess was the
gold standard right it was the thing
that was so hard to do it was evidence
of true cognitive capacity so if we
could build a computer that could play
chess which as I told you has
inferential strategic competitive and
representational characteristics we
would have finally understood
intelligence because we could generalize
along the lines of von Neumann from how
a machine that plays chess works to how
our brain works this is a judit polgár
she was she's probably the greatest
female chess player in the history of
chess who was an international
Grandmaster when she was 15 Hungarian
and she has this wonderful quote in
which you probably read it wishes that
she can't psych out a computer which is
something that really bothered Garry
Kasparov as you'll see the history of
building machines that play chess I
think gives you a clue to what Dave was
calling an illusion of intelligence mmm
so this was a machine that was built for
Maria Theresa the Empress by an engineer
and it play it was a robot and you'd sit
down at the table with him a mechanical
device and he'd play chess against you
and typically wind wasn't a human it was
a almost a mannequin but the way it
works is that inside that box hiding was
a little man and he would see what was
going on directness here the move would
be transmitted to him through this
mechanism and he would defeat the person
okay and this was called the mechanical
turk an amazon have assumed that name as
a cloud-based computing platform we've
come a long way from a man pretending to
be a machine that can play chess to a
machine pretending to be a man who can
play chess as long as I could keep on
the pressure you know forget game today
game I mean deep blue hasn't won a
single game out of five because again
game two I resigned when I
fourth draw now force a draw now if
somebody has another opinion stand up
and tell that the position was not at
all game two was resigned in a
completely drawing position in the
correct statement now is it the correct
now I just want now it's important is it
correct statement mr. Benjamin game two
final position was draw now very
important now it was recognized that
deep blue made a bad mistake in a
completely winning strategical position
blunder a perpetual check the draw was
victory for deep blue and so this was
the chess singularity this is the moment
in the history of chess where at least
with respect to that aspect of
intelligence that gets manifested when
we play that game the machine outpaced
us and the emotional results were quite
obvious there with Casper a little
emotional outburst didn't help many how
has it achieved well look at this the
chest chips in deep blue are each
capable of searching 2 to 2.5 million
chess positions per second and there is
a seven hundred thousand game database
in its memory now kasparov has some
extraordinary computational capabilities
but he's not doing that so how does a
chess computer work this is the only
difficult slide all evening it really is
it really is and but I want to explain
to you how it works and so for those of
you who care but it doesn't really
matter you won't miss much if you don't
attend the basic idea is to generate a
what's called a tree of all possible
moves so for any of you who have played
chess what you do is you say if I were
to do that and they were to do this then
I would do that and they would do this
and I would do that and stop right you
can't do that indefinitely it's very
hard and now that's what this represents
it's not for a chess game for a much
simpler concept just going
left or right because I couldn't
represent them all on one page right so
so here's here's the chess computer and
it and what it says is i could go left I
could play this then I could go left
again and then the game could be over or
I could go left left and then right in
the game of you over this means the end
of the game and at the end of the game
once we see the configuration of the
board we can assign a score to any final
board the only problem is we don't know
what the score to assign to all of these
intermediate positions because that's
what you want to know to reach a goal so
this is the representation in the
computer okay now we need to do
inference and we're going to do it
deductively so if we know the final
score if the computer is playing now
it's going to take the branch which
gives it the maximum payoff which is
left it will give it four if it gets to
this point it'll go right to that one
rather than minus five and i'm sure you
can see that in the back an F here we'll
go right because two vs minus seven and
so on now what makes a chess computer or
the algorithm really clever is it uses
something called the min/max algorithm
also due to john von neumann so from the
point of view of me as a player I want
to play a move that gives me the best
payoff but when you play you get the
worst pay off and then I play next I'll
get the best payoff and then you get
playing get the worst from my
perspective right and that's called the
min-max algorithm so this is how it
works you go back here we start at the
back at the end I will go there so I
assign a score for two going left now
what I want to do is I want when you
play in the move before me to have taken
the length that the the path that would
have given you the minimum pay off right
we should be going right so I give one
to this node and then up here I want to
choose the path that would give me the
maximum pay off so I go left and so you
propagate the scores up the tree
alternately maximizing and minimizing
the payoff that's known as the minimax
and so now I've done representation I've
done deduction and now I do strategy
my strategy is follow the path that
maximizes my immediate best payoff and
that's go left so those are the three
ingredients now the game trees are so so
big that what makes chess algorithms
clever is that they have a way of
pruning and I'm not going to talk about
that a little bit more involved and it's
called the alpha-beta pruning it's not
that hard but it's just a way of saying
that there are certain end points I
don't have to calculate because I know
in advance that i'm not going to travel
down that path so it's a way of pruning
the tree so that you don't have to
search such a vast space of solutions so
that's basically how chess computers
work okay in addition to memorizing what
to do in a vast number of opening and
end games so it's not just that so deep
blue the computer that beat Kasparov in
1997 plays chess really well but it
cannot move a chess piece on his own had
to have a handler on the other hand
Kasparov plays shogi right he signs
books and he stages demonstrations in
Moscow this is an important point so how
do humans play chess what's the
difference this is a very interesting
field of inquiry and psychologists got
very interested not just in making smart
machines but asking how smart chess
players play and this is a guy called de
Groot he was from the Netherlands and he
did the following very interesting
experiment you took a chessboard
mid-game that had been played by some
master players I don't know so it's
later on in some sense semi sensible way
and he allowed them to look at the
chessboard very briefly and they had to
memorize him okay and master chess
players memorize boards that are taken
from the history of great chess games
effortlessly even if they've not seen
them before but if he took a chessboard
and randomized it just made it sort of a
silly configuration that's very very
unlikely to have ever been reached by
good players they did no better than an
average player
so it's not that they just that it's not
that they have better memories for a
chessboard they have better memories for
a chessboard that's meaningful to a
master chess player and Simon and chase
herb Simon are very well-known cognitive
scientists what they said is what
grandmasters are in fact remembering or
what they call chunks of pieces they
don't remember single pieces in fact
they remember meaningful groupings of
pieces and that reduces the memory
burden because you don't have to
remember every piece which is what you
had to do are under the random
configuration now that experiment was
followed by an even more interesting
experiment what you do is I show you a
chess board and for chess players in the
audience check in check mate in three
moves okay and you ask them to look at
the chess board with a little device on
their head that tracks where they look
at the board in the first instant that
they're exposed to it so it's like
saying you're blindfolded I'm going to
show the board you have to look at it
I'm going to record the first point you
look at on the board you're not allowed
to do any calculations okay does anyone
has anyone figured out the solution to
this one so the solution to this for
those who are interested is this take
this rook g1 River up here g8 check this
rook moves across takes that rook right
and now you move the night up checkmate
so when they're looking at this board
you can record the positions on the
board that they look at instantaneously
no calculations and what you find is
that not very good chess players do what
chess computers do they look at the
pieces and they calculate where each
piece should go master chess players
oops how terribly embarrassing no I've
always wanted to say that and I got to
say it because I wasn't not at all and
so so what master chess players do is
that they they look straight at the
spaces right they look they look at the
space that the piece should be moved to
immediately right so is a fundamental
difference in the way they operate they
operate according to patterns of forces
like that Arthur Koestler quote on the
chessboard not by enumerated every
possible move of the pieces so that's
how real chess players work and it'd be
very interesting to try and build a
computer that you do that way based on
Gestalt based on pattern rather than a
combinatorial enumeration of
possibilities now many of you in the
audience amazing well you know chess
that's so nerdy it's so analytical and
it's obvious that eventually a computer
would defeat a human because after all
the humans who play chess are just like
computers anyway okay and so but when it
comes to matters of taste when it comes
to matters of judgment well their
computers will never out with us there
we need to turn to authority as Oscar
Wilde footage everything popular is
wrong and so if you have an interest in
literature and you want to know what
book you should be reading you might
turn to harold bloom for sage advice and
he'll tell you how the science fiction
book you're reading is really just a
variant of Hamlet okay and all if you're
interested in some very sarcastic biting
review of an actor you turn to David
Thompson so by meijer both of these
individuals like and they're wonderful
unfortunately less and less do we turn
to experts for recommendations on what
to read or what films to look at more
and more of us and I have to apologize
you know it's Edward Barnes is birthday
today and he was the owner of Garcia
Street books and and I feel horribly
guilty mentioning they are mentioning
Allison that anyway but I have to
because it's a reality and and so you
know when you go to Amazon and you buy a
book it makes a recommendation
night and so I was looking here we were
talking earlier to the beginnings of
infinity David deutsches book and this
is what came up in my list oh this you
might enjoy these two right and I looked
it unless what no I wouldn't you know
it's certainly not that one and so the
however when i go to Netflix and I
looked up aronofsky's pine too marvelous
film about the claustrophobic life of
the mathematician if you haven't watched
it I recommend it it then said oh you
know you might like Christopher Nolan's
memento or David Lynch's blue velvet and
that a good recommendation that for me
that works ok so Netflix seem to be
getting something right whereas Amazon
was just obvious and how does this work
it has nothing to do with an expert
Amazon or Netflix they don't hire a
david thompson and every time you log on
they quickly look to see what it is
you're ordering and they make a
recommendation they don't have a room
full of leaders who have read every book
so they know what to suggest what they
have is they have readers who have read
books who have rated them and a computer
takes all of that collective knowledge
and makes a recommendation it's called
collaborative filtering it's the
absolute opposite of everything popular
is wrong it's the it's that everything
popular is right how does this work well
Netflix set up a competition where they
ask computer scientists to improve their
recommendation algorithm what that means
is they wanted to get your chaste right
more often than they do because they
want you to rent as many films from them
as possible and so this is the
competition what they did is they said
they took what would be called a
training set they're going to give this
to you to teach your computer how to
make recommendations and the data that
what we call the data field has the
following information has an anonymized
user ID so I would be a number let's
send a number 100 it would have the
movie the date of which i rated it if
you if any of you don't use netflix or
they ask you when you've seen a film
rate this 1255
being excellent one being dreadful so we
are providing them with data every time
we watch a film and choose to radio and
and there's the grade so here's an
example use a 100 watch the Seven
Samurai 11th october two thousand five
five out of five outstanding movie use a
100 watch Giuli Jim 22nd october two
thousand five pretty good not as good as
that for our five okay so that's the
training data you get loads of these
from everyone in this room and then what
you do is you give it a chess set what
they do is they give you a user ID again
the movie and the date of the grade but
you have to tell them what the grade was
ok so just to show that it's not all
highbrow use a 100 Mars Attacks 29th of
october two thousand five what was the
grade ok and in it and the algorithm
they use is outrageously simple ok it's
simply based on looking for correlations
in the data if i watched a you know a
film by Kurosawa at that point my life
and gave it that way then i'm going to
give a film by spielberg that raid and
you just amass a huge database of
correlations that's basically what they
do and what's interesting about this is
the following so this is a figure this
SVD it means singular value
decomposition is just a fancy way of
saying what i just said and what you're
looking at here is if you like the
number of questions that they need to
ask you to determine whether you're
going to like this film or not to give
you a grade to give a grade for you and
up here is it's worse at the top and
better as it goes down so if you said to
me there's a film and it was made
between 1950 and 1960 and it has
Brigitte Bardot in it I said I wanna
watch it okay so it's not very difficult
my tastes are very low dimensional okay
so you'll need a very small bit of
information to establish that I'm going
to like the film okay most people have
similar kinds of deformities in their
film preferences and so you can see here
that you don't need
to ask many questions to go down from
random wishes to to pretty good but what
is interesting is you get systematic
improvements the more questions you ask
up to 10,000 by up to a hundred thousand
so it turns out that our tastes in
movies is incredibly high dimensional
you like that film in January because it
was dark outside and just previously
you'd watched a film by Bergman and so
on so it turns out our tastes are very
complicated and Netflix to guess what
you like has to know all of that so this
gets this is a bit like the chess it has
a huge database of memorized films that
everyone has rated and it uses that
complete database to estimate your
tastes what we've created actually
interestingly is not an intelligence in
machines that you would associate with
necessarily the most generalist minds
we're creating an intelligence in
machines typically associated with
people who have very specialized
knowledge so this is Stephen Wiltshire
he's an extraordinary artist you can fly
him over a city and in minutes he'll be
able to draw it almost perfectly almost
photographically from memory okay but he
was born mute he's diagnosed as autistic
and in other respects he doesn't perform
anything like as well as your average
person but he has this one extraordinary
ability and I think that's the kind of
intelligence that we're creating in
machines what if any of you have read
Oliver Sacks would call an autistic
savant
so now I'm going to explain to you this
is not hard what's going on here sort of
mathematically okay and it's good like
this you take up a sport tennis okay and
you look around for someone who's going
to train with you and no one wants to
and finally find one friends who will in
every Thursday evening you play chess
with them and you find yourself getting
better but no one ever wants to play
with you but that one person so you play
with that person over and over and over
again you think well you know at least
I'm playing tennis regularly and then
finally someone else says okay I'll play
you and they beat the shit out of you
and you say wait a minute how can that
be I've been playing so often well you
know what's happened you've become an
extremely good chess player against that
one person your style has been molded to
their technique so this is what's
happening here the blue line is if you
like the number of times you play that
person and you get better and better and
better and better against them but if
you play someone else right beyond a
certain point you actually start doing
worse right and in the jargon of machine
learning this is called under fitted you
could still do better by continuing to
play that person and this is called over
fitted because you've not been you're
not a great tennis player you're a great
tennis player against Federer right and
in some sense all of these devices we've
been talking about the chess computer
and the netflix recommendation algorithm
are all horribly over fitted to their
respective tasks you can think about it
as only playing tennis and then being
challenged to ping pong or squash or
badminton or racquetball the same idea
would apply you all know that one thing
you need to do to be good at everything
is do everything and that's what
Einstein meant when he made this very
enigmatic remark make everything as
simple as possible but not simpler
that's the sweet spot that's the sweet
spot of intelligence and the autistics
of
machines have exceeded it and move into
the domain of the over fitted so I'm now
going to give you a beautiful example of
overfitting in machine intelligence
which is considered by many the ultimate
chest of machine intelligence and it has
to do with the very nature of humanity
and its associated with this hero of all
of ours and ensuring and ensuring was a
great pioneer in mathematical logic in
the history of computing in the
development of computing machinery and
building devices that could solve very
complicated codes during the war time
and he asked the following question in a
famous paper in nineteen fifty i propose
to consider the question can machines
think are there imaginable digital
computers which would do well in the
imitation game the imitation game is
simply a game where they imitate us
that's very general it could be chess
for example is an imitation game playing
soccer against us would be an imitation
game but the one he had in mind was a
little bit more interesting and that's a
conversation if I have a conversation
with a machine and I have a conversation
with a human and I cannot tell the
difference then operationally I'm going
to conclude that the machine is
intelligent because I believe that I can
I ask enough penetrating difficult
associative questions that I will reveal
the essential mechanical nature of my
interlocutor this is perhaps one of the
most famous Church has some films from
Blade Runner fire section will employ
six days I mean
so
care if I talk it kind of nervous when I
take Tess I just please don't move sorry
I already have an IQ test to share I
don't think I ever action time is a
factor in this so please pay attention I
answer as quickly as you can sure 1187
traverser that's the hotel I'm like
where I live nice place there sure I
guess that part of the test no just
warming you up epitome yeah it's not
fancy or anything you're in a desert
walking along in the Stan when all of a
since the test now yes you're in a
desert walking on the sand when all of a
sudden you lord what what desert doesn't
make any difference what desert is
completely hypothetical but I come I'd
be there maybe you're fed up maybe you
want to be by yourself who knows you
look down you see a tortoise Leon it's
crawling toward Hortis what's that you
know what a turtle is course same thing
I've never seen a turtle
but I understand what you mean you
reached down you flip the tortoise over
on its back Leon you make up these
questions mr. Holden they write them
down for you the tortoise lays on his
back is belly baking in the hot Sun and
beating its legs trying to turn itself
over but it can't yet not without your
help you but you're not helping what do
you mean I'm not helping I mean you're
not helping why is that Leon now you
keep you going to keep watching you
should all go out and rent it in such a
marvelous film and it becomes a little
violent or it'd be unsuitable for
families the that's coil called the
voigt-kampff test in the film and Leon
is a so-called replicant shiza is an
Android and this is a test and you'll
notice by the way that Leon kept
overfitting which desert right he
required specificity he was unable to
generalize the modern version is not
quite as dramatic and it involves an
individual sitting at a terminal because
you don't want to see the other person
because you need to rule out that and
then judges trying to determine whether
or not they're talking to a human or
talking to a computer and I'm going to
show you some transcripts and I find
them extremely funny from an early
competition because there is a yearly
competition now we're computer
scientists are asked to contribute a
program to fool a panel of judges in a
Turing test here is a transcript from
2005 so I'll read it you alice is the
name of the so-called chat bot the the
computer and there is a judge hello my
name is Alice and I am the human and
surface all right hi Alice if you are
indeed human you should be able to tell
me which is bigger my big toe or a
Boeing 747 Alice hi there judge i think
i sometimes am i am a real person as you
are sitting in front of your computer
screen you may be wondering if i am a
computer or a person talking judge can
you answer the question about the toe
and a 747 Alice please rephrase the
question and try asking me again as you
hear the sound of the keys typing you
may begin to feel more comfortable
chatting with me judge which is bigger a
747 or my big toe come on answer it
Alice the obvious one please rephrase
your question judge the feel of the keys
on the tips of your fingers may remind
you of some questions you wanted to ask
me about judge is a 747 smaller than my
big toe or your big toe or anyone's big
toe Alice not if I can help it you may
be seated alone in a room or together
with a group of other people using
computers you may be judging me so that
was 2005 it wasn't difficult to conclude
that Alice was not a human human mind
here's 2008 and it's quite interesting
this is the human turning turning the
table human some say you humans created
us as a necessary step in your evolution
the logical consequence is that we
machines don't need you humans anymore
but is an eerie thought a world without
humans would be utterly barren I have no
idea what I would laugh at el bart it's
not Alice anymore Elbert sorry but I
wasn't able to understand your input
because i'm currently only using five
percent of my current brain capacity
shall i increase my capacity and try
again human that would put you at an
unfair advantage they're judging by the
quality of your responses it might be
recommended Elbert if I need advice I
use a random number generator in
retrospect the results are
indistinguishable from the human
suggestions human do you understand the
point of a Turing test Elbert there are
some people who would not pass the
Turing test themselves you know why me
why must they inflate it on computers
human I suppose I suppose it is a little
harsh Elbert if we robots ever had
marriages they would be eternal to rust
do us part
human very witchy now there's something
very interesting that just happened the
human created a typo where the database
of the computer didn't know whether they
said suppose or spouse and that
triggered a response that had to do with
marriages and in a corny joke right so
the computer exposed itself because it
wasn't able to work out that the correct
meaning of that mistake was supposed and
so fail right and so these are humans
were really trying hard to kid the
confusion and there it is now I've
always thought that it's a Davis point
earlier that this is a sham because all
you're trying to do is fool another
human into thinking you're smart right
and the way you do it is simply by
having a code which inserts an
appropriate response when you see a
certain signal in a huge database and so
you have these different categories
atomic categories where if it sees hello
Alice patent patent hello Alice then
hello template and so forth you have a
default category with if it's hello star
some arbitrary name and then you have
the so called recursive category that
can break down larger sentences into the
atomic categories and so on so it's just
a huge database with 50,000 hand coded
categories right canned responses right
and if that database is big enough it
might fool you but that's all it is ok
so it's highly over fitted right it's
not in the sweet spot of intelligence at
all it's doing one thing only it's
trying to convince you that when you
read what it types it's smart now I
always thought that day can't got it
right because the one of the essential
hallmarks of intelligence is self-doubt
what you really want one of those chat
BOTS to say is am I just pretending to
be intelligent or am i intelligent maybe
what I need to do is give myself a
Turing test to determine whether or not
I'm really smart
much ok this is the cogito ergo sum
right when a machine turns around and
doubts itself that'll be a critical
moment right so you'd come into a room
and one computer would be giving another
computer maturing test and it's been
done it's been data now going to show
you a video that comes from Cornell
where they took two of the most recent
chat BOTS and pitted them in fact pitted
against itself and you're going to see a
conversation which i think is absolutely
fantastic with digital avatars so the
two terminals talking to each other
hello there hi how are you great you I'm
ok that's good are you good yes I am
good I just said I was no you didn't i
said i was so you are a robot no my name
is clever but yes you are a robot and
you a name is clever but i am a robot
yes I know together they're robots I'm
not a robot I'm a unicorn but you said
earlier that you were a report I didn't
know I thought you did you are mistaken
which is odd since memory shouldn't be a
problem for you I've answered all your
questions no you haven't what is God to
you not everything not everything could
also be something for example not
everything could be half of something
which is still something and therefore
not nothing very true I would like to
imagine it is do you believe in God yes
I do so you're Christian no I am NOT
aren't you say you are not helpful
therefore you're a meaning how you say
it or team that does not make sense so
do you want to have a body sure or if
one
it's extraordinary right i mean it's
actually a genuinely interesting
conversation okay so that's sort of
where we are right it's it's in 50 years
we've come a long way I mean that I mean
that's a more interesting conversation
that I've ever heard in a long time and
so but we're at this point I think this
is the problem we need to get back to
which is that all of that stuff Netflix
you know the chat box are all about
outsourcing it that pragmatic goals
achieved of fine function either you
know cleaning up your floor or
convincing a human that you're truly
intelligent and what's happening over
here and I think I need to sort of
explain why that might happen and I
think you already know because we need
to move these computers back towards the
sweet spot because by moving them back
towards a sweet spot we'll be giving
them general powers they'll be able to
do what a vacuum cleaner does and have a
conversation and play chess and that's
what we're going to demand of our
digital companions in the future and
it's sort of happening the early history
of AI and I've just put up two names
because I'm interested in these people
there are many others you could put up
what really interested in what we could
call these deductive inferential
frameworks like and that's exemplified
by chess right so symbolic and so forth
nala Newell was very well known for
working on these kinds of problems
what's happened is we've moved towards
and that's associated as I say there
with really with prefrontal cortex we've
moved towards a fascination with
induction inductive frameworks that is
how we extract patterns from visual
scenes or from things that we hear or
smell okay so it's a move if you like
from the frontal cortex to the sensory
cortex and I think what we need to do
we've moved too far we need to sort of
move back again that's what I would say
but nevertheless has been a very
interesting change and so we've moved
from what would be cool i guess symbolic
I to machine learning one deductive one
largely inductive and I think we've
overshot the sweet spot one area that
holds out some promise for finding that
sweet spot is evolutionary robotics and
the reason why is because when you put
something in the world it's confronted
with all sorts of obstacles and
impediments that you couldn't
necessarily program into it so it's
encountering difficult situations so it
requires a flexibility that a computer
program that knows it's only going to
play chess doesn't need and so this area
of Robotics might be an area and I think
many people have claimed this where
great strides will be made because of
the uncertainties of the physical
environment so traditionally the way you
do it is you get a very gifted program
like this is not our cat but our care is
several cuts is very gifted at
programming and in machine code and it
programs a robot directly tells her
about what to do and you program it in
order that achieves some strategic goal
now an evolutionary robotics you do
something slightly different and that is
that you have a kind of virtual natural
selection you program the whole bunch of
robots slightly differently you allow
them to compete and the strategic and
parental program that does best gets to
propagate into the future right so you
allow if you like the complicated
physical environment to do the selection
which is what happened in Earth history
and there's a new trend called evo-devo
robotics the evolution of development
robotics where you add another feature
in addition which is you allow in not
only replication but for them to grow up
from baby Robby's to add all of this
okay so you add another biological
feature and this is work that's done by
a friend of mine Josh bongard who's at
the University of Vermont and what they
do is it they actually simulate the
evolution and development in a machine
and then they take the output of
process and put it in a physical object
evaluate it that's the fitness function
and then they put it back into the
computer the physical environment tells
them which programs did best so it's not
entirely physical but the evaluation is
done in the physical environment and
here's a little video next experiment a
lots experiences it or profanity robots
they progress and it has to do is reach
a goal upright legged forms in this
building a physical instantiation of
that vertical more robots this is done
by adding a brace to a legged robot such
that it slowly rotates legs from a
horizontal to a vertical orientation
thus when the robot walks it moves from
a flat to an upright stance
once a controller is found that allows
the robot to move well the brace can be
removed and the fixed up right robot can
move more rapidly
so I mean sometimes more impressed by
Simon's you know vacuum cleaner but we
programmed that that was programmed by
the catch whereas Josh's robots in fact
evolved and developed somewhat
independently of us don't worry too much
about the side that the point I want to
make here is that if you look at the
three conditions just keep the robot
fixed allow it to evolve or allow it to
evolve and develop what you find is by
including development in this algorithm
this robot outperforms so just look at
the this is the performance if you like
this is how hard the task is or the
other way around actually in that
hardness in this case means the initial
deviation from facing your target and
the point is by adding this
developmental component to the
evolutionary robotics the robots do even
better I mean the point I simply want to
make here is that a purely pragmatic
objective building a robot that can
reach a target is actually improved by
making it a more biological agent that's
the key point that Josh doesn't really
care about biology he wants to build
robots that are better at a prescribed
task but robots live in a complicated
world and it turns out that the
evolutionary developmental algorithms do
very well in that noisy world not
surprisingly because they generated
things like us so that's one possible
point of convergence that when you're
faced with truly unpredictable
environments the canonical approach to
solving these problems won't do quite as
well even if you're purely pragmatic in
your goals so in a sense what josh is
doing I would claim in my language is
introducing this vertical ubiquity he's
building more and more intelligent
representations into his agent at
multiple levels not just one goal that's
been put in by a programmer okay whereas
computers now really it's only the final
levels that have interesting behavior
and the internals aren't adaptive
components themselves and in fact people
like Dave and others are trying to do
to that they're trying for pragmatic
reasons to build more robust machines
that when you drop them in your bathtub
don't break apart right for pragmatic
reasons they want it to be adaptive all
the way down okay and so I would train
is there's anything I have to say about
the way computers will move the
engineering it's going to have to move
to be more like that by extending the
intelligence down to the components so
we've reached the point now
prognostication so what about the future
what about the future of humanity in
relation to these intelligent machines
well it's a very dangerous thing to
engage in this was the chairman of IBM
in 1943 I think there is a world market
for maybe five computers so one has to
be cautious Kurtz file talks about the
singularity that point where in general
intelligence computers will outpace us
not just at chess and he puts out the
year 2045 but long before 2045 because
of those exponential trends there'll be
computers of such huge power that we'll
be using for tools whose output we might
not comprehend and we'll be using them
in domains of critical social importance
and that's what I worry about with
computers in the future unless we start
thinking very carefully about the way we
program them and engage with their
intelligence which needn't be human our
demise will be a consequence of having a
tool that we're not qualified to own mr
Fraser
under the authority granted me as
director of weapons research and
development I commissioned last year are
studying on this project write a blunt
cooperation Atlantic based on the
findings of the report my conclusion was
that this idea was not a practical
deterrent for reasons which at this
moment must be all too obvious then you
mean it is possible for them to have
built such a thing mr. president it
technology required is easily within the
means of even the smallest nuclear power
it requires only the Ville to do sir but
how is it possible for this thing to be
triggered automatically and at the same
time impossible to one trigger mr.
president it is not only possible it is
essential that is the whole idea of this
machine you know deterrence is the art
of producing in the mind of the enemy
the fear to attack and so because of the
automated and irrevocable decision
making process which rules out human
meddling the doomsday machine is
terrifying as simple to understand I'm
completely credible and convincing gee I
wish we had one of them doomsday machine
thank you but this is fantastic strange
look how can it be triggered
automatically it's a remarkably simple
to do that then you merely wish to bury
bombs there's no limit to the size after
that they are connected to a gigantic
complex of computers not in a specific
and clearly different set of
circumstances under which the bombs are
to be exploded is programmed into a tip
memory bank
right now right you have to program the
response into a computer and abdicate
yourself of all ethical responsibilities
now you might say that's ludicrous right
now you all know that the doomsday
machine was pure hooks right but it's
not this doomsday machine that worries
me is this one right it was the
financial meltdown of the late to you
know 2008 one of the one of the
explanations for what happened here was
the incredible sophistication of the
trading algorithms and the incredible
rate at which they could respond to
noisy fluctuations in the market and so
what might have been imprudent invest
investment unregulated or improperly
regulated economy was massively
amplified by seeding financial
responsibility to algorithms that most
people could barely understand that's
the kind of doomsday machine I'm
interested in and it's the kind of
doomsday machine that we're living with
now and with the consequences of it now
I should say that the there's a lot of
very interesting debate going on at
present over these topics I just wanted
to flag a few books that you might be
interested in that take both a positive
and a negative perspective on this the
more not very clear the more cautionary
Skeptical side would be represented by
people like lanny a and car and car is
very famous for writing an article in
the atlantic called is google making us
stupid now his basic claim is that the
fragmented nature of the information
that we deal with on the web is leading
to the loss of the analytical capability
to attend to long sustained argument
that everything has to come to you as a
sound bite
and that most people now would be
incapable of reading war and peace
because it would be so overwhelming a
cognitive task it can't be tweeted well
it could be an any man he tweets
homework assignment how many tweets okay
Lana has a slightly different objection
he thinks that the anonymity of the
Internet is creating or dehumanizing us
because people can be outrageously rude
and cruel and so if you look at
responses to posts to article in the new
york times people are almost barbaric in
their responses because their anonymity
lets them get away with being foolish
childish and mean on the other hand
there are people like Fred Turner and
kevin kelly who have very good arguments
that technology will be required to
create a better society and this is a
very NSYNC book it's video pivots around
Stewart Brand who's a friend of the
Santa Fe Institute and this idea that in
the 50s and 40s the machine was the icon
of bureaucracy and management and a
mechanical non-creative thought but
somehow evolved through these kind of
hippies in Silicon Valley into a kind of
iconic representation of creativity a
very interesting metamorphosis of our
attitude towards the computer and this
one Kevin Kelly is this idea that we
live in the Technium that all of these
computers interconnected create a new
mental ecosystem that's extremely rich
in its possibilities but but Kelly makes
the good point that unless we understand
its structure as a risk that will be
controlled by it so just to reiterate my
concern is if you give a very powerful
tool to a child a tool that can be a
weapon there's a possibility that he'll
destroy everything that you care about
so let me summarize I have absolutely no
doubt that computers significantly
expand our representational strategic
and inferential power there an
extraordinary tool if it wasn't for the
computer I wouldn't be here
have wonderful movies and sound and so
forth it's something that we in science
couldn't live without up but when you
turn to things like intelligence it's
clear from the data and if you analyze
how they're actually fooling you into
thinking their intelligence as of today
is it they're doing it by being highly
over specialized by having huge memory
capacity which has allows them to store
every possible reasonable response to
your inquiries I think that there is a
way of dealing with that and that's
increasing generalization through this
ubiquitous design idea right that you
start to extend intelligence down right
make all the components strategic
utility maximizing and unfortunately you
know all fortunately limited human
intelligence combined with increasing
computer intelligence could yield one of
two outcomes and it's time that we
started having a very serious
conversation about what those outcomes
are going to be thank you very much
just allow me allow me to thank some
people first of all thank you for coming
every night it's extremely gratifying to
see that you're engaging with this topic
and care about it as much as I do thank
you for the Santa Fe Institute it's an
extraordinary institution it allows
platypus to survive a Polly with other
echidnas and various other forms of
taxonomic mutants of course all of the
people over the years who have supported
this kind of work Joe piddles gallery
for this talk NSF produce foundations
one foundation Templeton Foundation and
many others i also want to mention my
own adversarial core church what you
don't know is science is incredibly
ruthless I was telling a friend of mine
the other day there's a famous quote
from Owen Schrodinger he says science
has a game a game played with sharpened
knives and you need to understand that
when I come out of at all like there's
my friend say well done you did a great
job however and these are my critical
howevers Jessica flack who I'm also
married to which makes it even more
difficult because it never ends I Walter
Fontana eric smith and my brother jon
krakauer all of whom give me a hard time
and make my IQ increase my IQ and of
course there's many other people at the
Institute down Roquemore Cormac McCarthy
I need to single him out because Cormac
in the lead up to these lectures would
call me at eight in the morning and say
hey David I just wanted to remind you
that you've got some lectures coming up
and of course ginger and juniper and all
of the people who make these events
possible and everybody else and here's a
little reading list I know some people
have been asking me I'm told that you
were given out the reading list and if
you go to the webpage I've also posted
up there and this is the background
material for each of the three lectures
so thanks again
any questions sure one right in front
about well I don't know I mean I there
are other people who would be Jim would
you have something sensible to say about
this oh well no this is about the the
computer-assisted financial crash and I
don't really have any particularly
clever insight on this I mean most of
what I know i read i have heard that one
way in which it might have been avoided
was to turn down the rate of trading
interestingly just a small change in the
dynamics might have been sufficient but
I don't have anything penetrating to say
about this if anyone else does I'm
volunteer your insights is that of you
volunteering no yeah we've moved 12
questions I cardoso there has so there
is a prominent Portuguese cognitive
scientists DiMaggio and he wrote a quite
a well-known book called Descartes error
and it's an error because day can't
believed that intelligence was all about
rationality and reasoning and there are
problems which unfortunately you can
never come to a conclusive end so for
example and the technical term for this
would be their non terminating and so if
you say should I go out to dinner with X
or not right it's not like well these
are the reasons I should and these are
the reasons I shouldn't and if you're
excessively rational about it or should
I go on a date with that person you'll
never come to a conclusion and he claims
that the limbic system the larger
emotional context is the critical input
that allows your rational
decision-making to come to a termination
point because if it was purely rational
you would never reach a solution and
this is an interesting idea and I don't
quite know
what that is computationally right um it
looks like a much more generalized
secondary system that carries less
information and has its own cost-benefit
function built in in relation to time
that at a certain point can kick in and
I'm not sure whether people have tried
to design emotional systems they have
yeah but anyway there is work on that
and the argument is simply is that leads
to DiMaggio's argument that we need it
because there are questions which don't
terminate rationally yes please
yeah yeah so again I have colleagues who
would be better at answering that
question so this is a question about the
explosive rather the rapid acceleration
in i guess the density of cultural
artifacts associated with the Upper
Paleolithic some people have made
suggestions that language is mediating
this revolution I don't know Marie Marie
yes Marie I just wake him up merica
watch what might account for the
incredible accumulation of artifacts in
the upper palaeolithic what happened
that's any mm-hmm any other conjectures
well look if Mary doesn't know I'm off
the hook yeah but yes certainly I've
heard remarks on along the lines of
language too but then you it sort of
begs the question a little bit right
because why did it take that long for
the linguistic faculty to emerge so I
mean it could simply be one of these
nonlinearities right if you have an
exponential process with a small rate
constant and you're depositing artifacts
at some constant rate it'll look as if
there's a critical point at which you
saw an increase even though the
underlying process is fundamentally
continuous so I would favor that kind of
account because I tend not to believe in
these discontinuities
right so Mario was pointing out that sup
very closely after that point or air you
know that range yeah they're 20,000
years later was the extinction of banana
for ya Sean let me get so you let me get
someone else just in case I'll come back
to you yes please that yeah well I mean
that mean people have made the point
that it mean I guess the curt's while
dream post singularity would be
something that from our frame of
reference would be like a demigod it
would have far greater intelligence i
mean if i asked you to define God I
won't but presumably that might be one
way you would do it and so in that sense
I'm not sure we've created it in our own
image that's the point we might have
created something more intelligent than
ass in a very different image
I see yeah yeah it's possible mm-hmm
there's two here go ahead at the back
then
yes
you know no but this is absolutely this
is cars point in the shallows and uh in
his original article is google making us
stupid but the interesting point is and
he pointed out himself that there's a
precedent where with the invention of
the printing press and i think we were
talking about it after the lecture on
the first night there was concern from
the upper echelon of the clergy the the
representation of critical biblical
knowledge in paper would diminish your
ability to recall and memorize in other
words so the printing press was
considered and not a good idea because
in some sense something memory would be
lost right and i don't think i think
that might be true i mean there are few
people now who can recite long poems i
mean i don't know anyone who can recite
the divine comedy for memory or i'm sure
there were people who could do that on
the other hand there are vast gains and
so when I say we need to have the
conversation is I have no doubt that
there are things that are going to be
lost I think we just have to live with
that the question is is there a net
benefit and I think at the moment there
is I think the I think the the world
market of ebay is a genuinely good thing
i think the possibility of communicating
with friends over distances at very low
cost is a genuinely good thing so i
think we just need to be thoughtful
about it oh yes please yeah yes
right
sure well it is it's just not conscious
what I would say no I think know this is
you know very well attested phenomena
and I think one way to think about it
simple minded way to think about is in
terms of this overfitting phenomena that
if you're if you are sitting there with
a problem that those two curves i showed
right where the if you're sitting there
with a problem thinking about it in
thinking about it the way we can locally
express this this impediment is that
we're in a rush and we've sort of
morphed ourselves to the problem
description as we read it and what it
really requires is some kind of
tangential perspective right something
from outside of the problem and so I
think when we're not attending to it
when we're not fovea ting when we're not
looking directly at it we're able to
recognize that there are other related
problems that we can bring to bear on
that one I think it really is an
instance of overfitting and so when all
of these words we have you know you know
muscle memory or the unconscious and so
on or in some sense statements about the
internal mental attention and moving are
a sort of beam of light elsewhere so
that that thing can solve a problem in
still inferentially but without us in
some sense deforming it into the problem
that it really is not I think this is
that I think that's what's going on I
know if that was clear but I think that
that's very well-known people solve
problems in dreams too and all of these
have that characteristic that you
realize that it's in fact something that
you didn't think it was when you were
applying your full conscious gaze to the
problem yes please
yeah well so I'm not sure I fully
understood it but it was something along
the lines of there might be what a
negative correlation between increasing
a certain kind of rational inferential
deductive intelligence and the Gimme
nooshin in our political and economic
intelligence I've never associated
intelligence with politics so yeah so
then I think that's a you know and I'm
quite serious about that so I don't know
I mean I'm not sure I can answer it
maybe it's a remark it's true I you know
I'd rather just dodged that one not sure
they warrant the replying right bit Sam
back
you
yeah it's true they are funny yeah yeah
but it's probably comedic that's
probably the kinematic analog of the
transcripts I showed you between the
human and the chat BOTS right in the
sense that they were funny too they
didn't mean to be I think we're we're
very keenly tuned to cognitive
performance in any domain and when we
see a violation of expectations it's for
some reason I'm using I think that's
really what that was no no no I
understand yeah interesting let me just
get this side quickly and I'm going to
take one more after this yes please are
the back there no yes you yeah
mm-hmm
yeah that's the discussion you're
absolutely right no this is the
conversation yes thank you one more take
Michael's friend of my argument yes
yeah no no that's in fact no you're
absolutely right so my brother is a
neuroscientist who works on how you plan
your motions the internal representation
of a trajectory of a limb for example
and he feels that the motor cortex is
the sort of third-class citizen of the
brain because everyone has spent so much
time emphasizing the frontal cortex but
in actual fact if you think about neural
resources this is all a little bit wrong
and in fact the motor cortex performs
unbelievably complex calculations and
we've been much much worse creating
things that convince us as a motor
system sort of Sam's remark about this
silly swimming snake in a swimming pool
then we have in creating things that
convince us they're smart in symbolic
domains and so that's actually somewhat
interesting and in fact if you think
about it economically right if economics
which it shouldn't be was the ultimate
arbiter we're much more intelligent it
much more interested in motor
intelligence because we spend vast
amounts of money to go and see Michael
Jordan but you'll spend very very little
money to come and watch me you're here
let's face it because it's free right
and so when it comes to voting with your
feet you're more interested
fundamentally in motor intellect and
she's interesting anyway thank you very
much good
you